hello everyone and welcome to the other
match of the
gold money asian rapid knockouts so
we're in the semi-finals and it's
vladislavia versus ding liran
and uh much like levon auronyan artemyev
also lost
the first match so now he needs to win
the second match in order to force tie
breaks and then
try to maybe eliminate ding in the tie
breaks if
if not in the blitz section then maybe
in armageddon and it was a really really
intense match and
this is um i think the the highest
quality
game of the match uh because in the
second match uh the the
the first game started by them drawing
the game then
uh artemiev won the game and he bounced
back into the match but then
ding won the third game and then again
artemis is in a must-win situation so
this is game four
of the rapid section and artemiev simply
must win to force tie breaks and somehow
get back into the match and it's always
unpleasant being in a
must-win situation but at least you have
the white pieces and
the opening he chooses and the way he
plays is most
interesting so let's see how it how how
it went for him
uh so without further ado uh let's check
it out artemis with
the white pieces opens with d4 we have
knight to f6
uh b4 uh we have d5 and now e3 he goes
for for the london system setup we have
c3 biting
and knight to c3 now uh we have c
captures on b for e captures and
now a6 so this has been played many
times uh nothing
nothing new here we have knight to f3
knights the c6
and not knight to e5 and this is
something uh the the
london players use very often they will
shift this knight over to e5
and if they feel very aggressive uh then
the knight end queen as you can see
guard the g4 square so you can already
start pushing g for g5 h4 h5
and it's sort of a um well a barbarian
uh
type of thing to do but uh you know when
you're in a must-win situation
uh you could go for something like this
and black might even consider capturing
here on e5 but it's a very unambitious
uh idea for black for example if d
captures you're going to lose this pawn
uh if you move the knight so you have to
go into this d4 line and then after e
captures captures we're going to trade
queens we have captures captures and
now uh after uh well f captures on g7
and we're going to capture
not g7 but you could also capture on e7
so the bishop doesn't
grab hold of this diagonal bishop
captures or king captures and then we're
going to capture on c3
and it's going to be uh well it's going
to be a much better position for white
both players still have the bishop pair
and yes white's pawns are doubled but
i'm sure there's a very good reason for
being not to do this as
it's still a pawn up so how however we
put it um and i'm not saying ding
wouldn't be able to draw this but
uh it's not not the way to play chess so
instead bishop to d7 he just continues
um
developing and now we have a very very
interesting move uh here
known moves are some like queen to d3
you could also continue with bishop to
e2
uh maybe push upon but here we have the
early g4 and it's not a new move it has
been played once
uh but now uh the g4 square nicely
defended by the knight and by the queen
you are
preparing to dislodge the knight further
on with g5 and so on
so here uh there is a game where knight
captures an e5 was played but here
ding says i'm not very impressed with
your g4 move he just plays e6
and it is now as of move 8 that we have
a completely new game
so uh artemio continues with his plan
with g5
now he trades on e5 knight captures on
a5 and now
uh we have bishop captures on e5 if you
continue uh with
g captures on f6 then we can just play
knight to g6 and this only helps black
you're going to lose the pawn now
otherwise you can play something like
captures captures
but again this only helps black develop
and black will be perfectly fine here
so instead after knight captures on e5
we have bishop captures
and now knight back to g8 uh we have
queen to h5
full barbarian mode on uh as now that
you see the bishop here the queen here
the bishop coming to d3
uh it could be very scary but the ding
says i'm again not very impressed
knights to e7
and now bishop to d3 we have knights to
see
things being just continues developing
and now we reach the position from the
thumbnail
uh artemia pushes g6 and
this is just a wonderful position point
is that the g6 pawn
should not be captured if you capture it
it's not going to be good for you of
course if you capture with this pawn
then you lose the rook
and if you capture with the f pawn well
then we just capture with the bishop and
you are getting checkmated here
h captures queen captures you're gonna
play king to e7
now comes knight captures on d5 with
check and the black king has no squares
you have to capture the knight and after
you do this then we have this beautiful
bishop queen checkmate as there is
nowhere for the black king to go
so this is definitely in the position
but the ding of course not about to fall
for
such a such a cheap trick he goes knight
captures on e5
and okay the captures on e5 and now
uh this shows you how uh how crazy this
position is and how
well uh wonderful the london system can
be if if
used properly uh ding ding's knowledge
of theory ends here as he plays queen to
e7 but here you actually have to go into
f captures on g6 and i'm just going to
show this to you because it's a super
super fun line because you know bishop
captures on g6 is coming so
there's really no reason to play this
but this is the strongest move that's
how
sometimes chess works uh but i will show
it f captures bishop capture so we
check and now we give up the rook h
captures queen captures
and now we play d4 we dislodge this
knight and now we free this diagonal for
our bishop we can bring the queen into
the game with czech so
a lot of possibilities here so knight to
e4 white is very happily coming with the
knights to d6 but we don't care just
bishop the c6
attack the knight and if the knight
moves the rook so knight to d6 with
check but now we're gonna play king to
d7 and here what do you play
uh well there are a couple of things you
could play uh you could play something
like rook to g1 but
that's not not very ambitious for white
just queen to a5 with
check and now you see that uh the the
the white king doesn't really have
all that many squares you have to play
king to f1 and then it's just ugly
uh so instead what you could do is just
castle decides to give a little bit of
material back this
is considered strongest for white but
then queen to g5 would
check and now we just eliminate the e5
pawn king king b1 queen captures on e5
now attacking the knight
and only when the knight moves now we
can play queen to c5 and we get this
position where
uh black is up the exchange but a white
is up the exchange but
black is is considered better here since
uh you you have to move the knight
then we can start advancing the pawns
and it's uh well it's just
very ugly if b3 we can play b5 and so on
uh but just wanted to show you how how
crazy uh you know sometimes the the
strongest idea may be but being played
queen to e7
and now uh artemiev just castle
queenside being also castle queenside
and he allowed the capture of this f7
pawn but
he doesn't care he's going to win it
back so g captures on f7 we have g6 now
attacking artemis queen
and now bishop captures on g6 and now
bishop to g7
so this is how ding gives back a little
bit of material to activate his pieces
so bishop back to d3 now the bishop is
hanging as the rook is nicely defended
here
so bishop back to d3 and now rook f2
rook d f8 with a double attack on the
pawn here
we have knight to e2 and now just queen
captures an f7 and now they can grab the
f7 pawn
uh uh artemia exchanges queens here we
have as
the f2 pawn is hanging so you could play
f4 maybe but
if you go f4 to defend it like this then
you blunder your queen so you can't do
that
so uh here we have a trade captures
captures and
now f4 and if you look at the position
now uh it's six points to five so
artemiev is up upon but
again ding has the the bishop pair he's
not all that worried about this so
how can vladislav do anything to to
cause
some problems you know to maybe create
some complications in the position it's
not going to be
easy but it is his last hope because if
he doesn't win this then
uh it's ding to the to the finals at the
face level
so here we have bishop to h6 he knows
that he's going to win this spawn
because it's pinned the king is on c1
and now
the other rook is coming here so ding is
even winning the pawn uh but
there's the problem of the h7 pawn
however again ding is not worried so
rook after d1
that's not a rook dita f1
uh defending here but not just rook h2
f8 with a triple attack here and now
king to d1 unpinning but now uh ding
just eliminates this pawn
so rook captures we have rook captures
knight captures rook captures and now
bishop captures an h7 and now again rtm
is up upon it's a past h pawn
but ding plays rook h4 and he says that
that pawn is not
going anywhere so bishop back to d3 and
now another very important
move d4 we have to free this diagonal
for the for our light square bishop
and then it's just going to be very good
for us with h3
now you know this is coming so you have
to free up this square for the rook
bishop to c6 and now rook to h2
and now again we have king to d7 dean
starts bringing his king into the game
because that's what you do when you're
in an end game
and bishop to f1 defending the pawn here
so now the rook can once again be
activated with bishop to e4
uh and now rook to d2 attacking this
pawn but now a nice trick by being
king to c6 not saying okay if you grab
this pawn
then i'm going to play the bishop f3
check and then i'm going to pick up the
rook and
i win so artemis has to unpin he plays
king the e1
now there is a threat of just capturing
this because the king is no longer in
the line of check
and now comes the bishop to f5 biting
and this is a
this is a very interesting decision by
thing uh
okay it's going after the h3 pawn but
bishop here uh
is uh simply not allowing white to
activate his bishop so while it is
possible
uh ding's idea is different he plays
bishop to f5 and you'll see later on uh
why ding plays this and why his vision
is as
great as it is so bishop to g2 check he
abandoned
this diagonal so of course vladislav
claims that for himself king to c5
and now king to f2 we have b5 now
uh there's always time to grab this
spawn so you don't
have to rush this we have king to g3
attacking the rook
rook not h7 but rook to h8 accidentally
dropped the rook there
we have a3 and now comes a5 by d
so again how can you do anything here it
seems like black has such a firm grip on
the position that there's simply
no way to try anything we have bishop to
f1
now even b for by being with cactus
captures and
now b3 and now you see what being had in
mind and now the bishop here
uh guard attacks the c2 pawn which is a
backward spawn and there's no way this
pawn is ever reaching the c3 square
and artemia will be stuck here guarding
it for for the rest of the game so
uh is it time for uh you know for
artemis to
re just resign and you know say it was a
good match ding thank you
uh nope uh he will he will still try
ding first goes to rook to g8
check king to h2 now rook to h8 ding is
happy with the draw he says okay
is there anything you want to try king
g3 ding repeats
king rook the g8 check and now we have
king the f4
so uh starting to bring the king a
little bit deeper into the position
we have rook to f8 by ding now
threatening some nasty discovery is now
king to g5 by artemyev uh we rook to g8
and now king to f6
we rook the g6 check now king to e7 and
we often say that
there's a there's an active king but
there's also a two active king
and this king is well extremely active
but it doesn't seem like there's
anything for this king to do
there i mean it's just not attacking
anything it's not being very helpful
uh what can you do here uh we have kink
to d5 by ding
and now bishop to c for check we have
king captures on e5 and now okay
we trade pawns dean will win this pawn
after rook to e2 check
king to f4 and now bishop captures an e6
we have bishop captures and now rook
captures on e6
and now uh it's a it's a very
interesting position because uh well
it's it's a rook end game of course
artemis is still up upon
but what do you play here uh there's
actually not all that much you can play
and you have to be very careful there
are two moves that are good for black
and no other move is good for black so
feel free to pause the video here
and try to find the only two moves that
are good for ding while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on not
trading rooks obviously we don't trade
rooks if we're down a pawn uh
and uh well if you found uh rook the g2
or rook to g3 then congratulations uh
you are a most excellent
rook and game player uh because only
rook the g3 and rook to
g2 are are good uh for those of you who
who are skeptical i will show you if you
trade rooks here then white is just up a
pawn i mean that's uh
uh that's too strong if you go here then
white will win both of these pawns then
advance his two queen side pawns and if
you go the other way king e3 may be
trying to win this pawn and then try to
advance this one
now we don't push the pawn i know you
guys were thinking about pushing the
pawn
we play king d5 so now black can't get
away from the pawn because he loses this
pawn
but there isn't another move because now
we simply advance our pawn if king here
then king captures king captures on c2
now we're going to defend it and now
advance our pawn to victory
so the other thing that i mentioned is
rook the g2 is winning because okay
if rook to g2 there is simply you know
you're going to win this spawn
or you're going to go after this pawn so
not winning it but not losing this is a
dead draw black black can never win this
but uh black
must not lose this so rook to g2 pretty
much self-explanatory
and rook to g3 also possible because now
uh for example if king d6 we're gonna
play d3 and now
all of white's pawns just you know get
annihilated c captures rook captures
we're attacking both of the pawns uh
whatever you play king c5 just rook
characters on b3
and this is now a dead draw however ding
played
one move that is not one of the moves
that i described
being played rook to g7 check and now uh
that simply will not do it it doesn't
seem like it changes all that much but
the chess
is ruthless like that uh what it
actually does is it
brings the white king closer to the
d-pawn and that's
that's huge in this position now after
playing this ding now goes back with
rook to g2 trying to do the same idea
that we discussed
but now the king is already here the
king is not here so now
king d5 now attacks the d4 pawn this
would never have been possible if
you know rook to g3 or rook to g2 was
played right away
so here ding grabs the c2 pawn but now
rook the e4
check now the king defends the d4 square
and now the white rook will gobble up
all of these pawns maybe
so king f5 now rook captures on d4 we've
rooked to c3 and now
rook captures on b4 uh ding will now
claim this pawn but first rook to d3
check
king c5 rook the c3 check king d4
and now rook captures on h3 and now
white is up only one pawn and usually
when it's a rook's end game and you're
up only one pawn
uh it's very very hard to win in most
cases it's not even possible but here
uh rook the b6 bartamiev and now you can
see that
the white king and rook completely cut
off the black king from entering uh well
the side of the board where the past
pawn is at and there's simply no
no stopping the pass pawn the rook alone
will not be able to do it
so rook the h1 biting but now b4 uh we
have rooked the d1
check king to c5 now king e5 uh he did
win some squares for the king but it's
not enough rook to h6
we rook to c1 check king to b6 now king
d5 but now
b5 rook to b1 and now comes king
to a6 now if rook a1 we're going to go
here to to b7 and then advance our pawn
so king to c5 but now we have rook to c6
with
check uh you could also just play b6 the
pawn can never be captured but
artemis decided to do it in a in a nicer
way rook to c6
check king d5 and now rook the c2
completely cut off the king now from
entering the game this way
and now there's simply no stopping the
pawn rook a1 check we have king to b7
rook to b1 now comes b6
we have king to d6 and now rook to d to
check there are many ways you can win
this but artemis
chooses now the most elegant one he
invites the black king closer to the
past pawn king to c5
and now even plays king to c7 he says go
ahead and grab my pawn
but of course there is there is no
grabbing the pawn and it was in this
game on move 69
that dingler and resigned in the game
and vladislav artemyev
won the second match which was
incredible because he was able to force
tie breaks and
in the tie breaks uh first game where
ding had the white pieces ended in a
draw
but then in the second game where
artemiev again had the white pieces
he was able to win and he was able to
eliminate the ding so it's really
incredible that both uh
levon arenan and the vladislav came into
the match against
magnus sending uh well being down a full
a full match point
they bounced back and they won the tie
break so really uh
incredible and i think we're going to
have an absolutely incredible
uh final slavonna arun versus vladislav
artemis
playing the probably the most beautiful
chess out of the
all of uh the players in the top 20 and
artemis who is just uh
who's just so powerful now he plays also
as you as you've seen he just kept
pushing those pawns he kept coming at
the ding
and i i think it's gonna be uh i think
it's gonna be an incredible final match
and
it's gonna be a treat for for all of us
uh so here
like i said you resigned because now the
pawn is getting promoted and of course
if you capture it then just rook c2
check and there's no defending the rook
you can defend it one more time
rook b2 checking moves we're going to
capture the rook and then
adjust checkmate just checkmated the
king with the king and the rook
uh so really incredible stuff artemis
bounces back
and eliminates ding i i don't think um
uh well everyone expect expected artemis
to do well but it's just
when ding plays well there's just no
stopping him and this game
incredible is this ding played
incredible chess
but it simply wasn't enough artemis just
kept finding ways to keep the game going
going going going going and
then like all of a sudden you know
there was that one moment where ding had
the opportunity to make uh make a
mistake you know and he gave this check
uh i put the quote above the board
patricia czech potter gives a check a
famous bobby fischer quote
uh of course not saying that ding is a
part so i just did it for
for comic effect uh no no disrespect to
ding of course thing is uh
uh you know a spectacular player uh but
you know i thought it was fitting in
this one because you know you just have
to go after the pawns but then you give
a check and then you blunder the game
uh but yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh see you today in the
finals uh live slovakia versus lavon
aaron
it's going to be incredible uh i would
like to thank uh david pierce tom derala
missing a t there sorry tom uh lens
hassan uh connor clark and james walker
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing today with
the finals of the gold money asian rapid
thank you
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your weekend